[Music]
in
49 bce a provincial governor named
julius caesar led an armed insurrection
against the senate and people of rome
he commanded 10 legions which was a lot
and although they remained
personally loyal to him most of them
were hunkered down all the way up in
gaul for the winter
only one the 13th legion was in any
position to be of use
in the short term at half strength the
13th consisted of approximately 2 500
soldiers
and the moment these soldiers crossed
into italy it amounted to a declaration
of war
way up in gaul caesar's close friend and
right-hand man labienus had been left in
charge of caesar's legions
in his absence labienus knew that there
was a political back and forth going on
in the south but
assumed that everything would be fine
well everything was not fine
when negotiations broke down news
started trickling in that caesar had
risen up in open rebellion and was in
the process of marching on rome
labienus was shocked let's not forget
that up until this moment the venus's
achievements in gaul had been truly
remarkable
he had spent the last 10 years leading
semi-independent military operations in
caesar's name
labienus was the only man caesar trusted
to take command
of the republic's largest army in his
absence in fact i would argue that
labinus deserves half the credit for the
conquest of gaul
unlike caesar labienus actually lived on
deployment with the legions
and unlike caesar labienus's military
record was an unbroken string of
victories
without any exaggeration the venus was
up there with pompey and caesar as one
of rome's greatest
living generals and this fact may have
caused some animosity
had labienus devoted the last 10 years
to his own advancement rather than
caesar's he would have been one of the
most
influential men in rome now labenus was
over 50 and if he was ever going to
translate his military success
into political power it was going to be
as one of caesar's men
caesar noticed this shift in attitude as
time went on he granted labienus more
and more independence and gave every
indication that the gallic provinces
would be his whenever caesar returned to
rome
finally labienus would get an
independent command
some whispered that the consulship might
follow
[Music]
but then caesar rose up in open
rebellion against the senate and people
of rome
from what we can tell he didn't even
bother to consult with labienus before
doing so
labenus was angry i would've been angry
too labenus had hitched his wagon to
caesar
and now caesar had decided to foolishly
run off a cliff
and it wasn't all about ambition if we
are to believe labienus's surviving
words which in fairness come to us
through biased sources
he considered taking up arms against the
senate morally
repugnant absent any data to the
contrary i see no reason not to believe
him
this was the most important decision of
his life
and taking his reasoning behind it
seriously is the least we can do
without too much fuss labenus
immediately left camp
accompanied by a large contingent of
cavalry that were personally loyal to
him
he made no attempt to bring along any of
caesar's legions
once free labienus publicly denounced
caesar as a traitor
and pledged his loyalty to the senate he
would join up with the pompeians in
italy
this was an unexpected blow to caesar
the two had been close friends for at
least
14 years probably longer labienus had
earned caesar's absolute confidence
it was a big deal but for what it's
worth
labienus made no attempt to stab caesar
in the back by stealing his legions he
could have
but he didn't that's worth something
caesar ordered his men back in gaul
to pack up labienus's personal
belongings and have them shipped to
italy
some historians have described this as a
callous reaction to a loss of a friend
but i don't see it that way at all
the venus had lived in gaul for 10 years
and then
just walked away with nothing to my eyes
it's a small act of compassion to be
like
sure follow your conscience if you must
but you're going to need all your stuff
once you get back to italy
when cicero learned that labienus had
defected from caesar he wrote
labienus seems to have condemned a
friend of his of a crime for the sake of
the republic
continuing he wrote i judged labienus a
hero
it has been a long time since a more
glorious political move
if labienus has accomplished nothing
else he has caused caesar pain
i would add to cicero's thoughts if
labienus had accomplished nothing else
he had deprived caesar of a skilled
lieutenant in that respect he was
irreplaceable
[Music]
when news traveled south there was panic
on the streets of rome
the senate was as surprised as anybody
they had been keeping a close eye on
caesar's legions
north of the alps if these legions moved
they told themselves
that meant that caesar was gearing up
for an invasion
well those legions hadn't moved caesar
invaded anyways
[Music]
now the recriminations began the
warhawks in the senate
started pointing fingers arguing that
pompey had walked them into this mess
it's not true by the way if anything it
was the other way around
the war hawks walked pompey into this
mess
there were legions mustering to the
south but they wouldn't be ready for
some time
and even when they were these raw
recruits wouldn't stand much of a chance
against caesar's hardened legion there
were more experienced legions in
spain and greece but it would take
months to get them over to italy
in the defense of the pompeians it was
winter and they had assumed that they
would have months to get ready
they were just wrong in rome those who
could
packed up their belongings and fled the
city when cicero learned that caesar's
march south was creating a steady stream
of roman refugees
he remarked are we talking about a roman
general here
or hannibal pompey could see no way
around it
he would not be able to mobilize a
resistance in time
he would have to temporarily abandon the
city of rome
his reasoning was sound he had access to
the vast
resources of rome's provinces he had
more legions
he had more money he had the senate on
his side
the longer this conflict continued the
stronger pompey would become
caesar's only hope was to force an early
confrontation
by pulling back pompey denied caesar
this opportunity
it was the right call under the
circumstances
but that doesn't mean it was popular
being forced to abandon the capital
isn't
a great way to start a war rome's most
prominent senators
violently disagreed with the decision
cicero was particularly upset
he asked pompey whom he had been
privately calling the senate's
incompetent leader
if he intended to make a stand in
southern italy
pompey wouldn't give him a straight
answer cicero reluctantly agreed to obey
the senate's order but decided not to go
with pompey
he would remain in the italian
countryside ready to return to rome at a
moment's notice
[Music]
the young senator marcus junius brutus
was also
quite torn on paper it should have been
a no-brainer since his beloved uncle was
none other than the arch-conservative
cato
but it was more complicated than that
brutus's mother was caesar's longtime
mistress
and the two men seemed genuinely
affectionate towards each other
plus there was an additional wrinkle
when brutus was a child
pompey had personally ordered the death
of his father
the hatred ran deep to this day brutus
could barely bring himself to speak to
the man
after an intense period of soul
searching brutus decided that the
republic's integrity was more important
than his personal feelings
he pledged his loyalty to his father's
killer and accompanied pompey into
southern italy
domitius aheno barbus another powerful
senator
was angry domitius was the guy who had
been selected by the senate to replace
caesar in gaul whenever he resigned his
command
now domitius was one of the many who
were furious at pompey's decision to
abandon the capital
without bothering to consult with pompey
or
the rest of the senate domitius grabbed
10 000 militiamen and raw recruits
and marched north he would stop caesar's
advance
or die trying
this was not as crazy as it might seem
against caesar's one
half strength legion domitius would have
outnumbered him four to one
however things had changed in the last
few weeks as soon as he crossed the
rubicon
caesar split up his tiny legion and
captured five cities in rapid succession
all uncontested one of these detachments
was led by mark antony
who i would like to note was still
technically a tribune of the plebs
tribunes were forbidden to leave rome
while in office
and not only had antony left the city
but here he was
returning at the head of a rebel army
things were so chaotic at this time that
it never even occurred to anybody to
strip him of office
but they should have now that caesar had
a foothold in italy he ordered his
legions north of the alps to join him
he spent the rest of january capturing
cities in the north
apart from one tiny skirmish all of the
defending garrisons either fled
or defected to his side with
reinforcements coming down from the
north
and defectors coming up from the south
caesar's one legion ballooned into
five or six by early february domitius
aheno barbus arrived at the town of
corfinium with ten thousand men
which equaled like two legions caesar
would have to pass this way before
heading further south
domitius knew that for him this was
probably a one-way trip
but if everything went well it would
give pompey enough time to marshal his
resources
and march north intercepting caesar
before he reached rome
when caesar's legions showed up outside
the walls of corphinium the civilians
inside the town
immediately lost heart and tried to
surrender
besieged and with no sign of support
from pompey
domitius's ten thousand recruits and
militiamen
realized that this was a suicide mission
they mutinied
against their commander opened the gates
of the town
and hauled domitius before caesar
demetius was humiliated he begged for
death
believing that the execution of a former
consul would serve as a rallying cry for
the rest of italy
instead caesar surprised everybody by
publicly
pardoning domitius and letting him walk
away a free man
caesar justifies his clemency by saying
that he had no interest in alienating
politicians or the public with
unnecessary brutality
if he was victorious he wanted his
victory to last
and to do that he would need the
cooperation
of his former enemies
that's the reason he gave the real
reason might be a little less
high-minded
when domitius's ten thousand men
discovered that caesar had pardoned
their former commander many broke ranks
and volunteered to join caesar's legions
now domitius was angrier than ever he
immediately began planning a second
high-risk operation to save the republic
he'd be back
by now caesar had approximately six
legions in italy
while pompey was still struggling to
rally two or three legions in the south
pompey began to seriously consider
abandoning the italian
peninsula the pompeians still held the
overall advantage
even though locally they were
outnumbered in time
the combined strength of the provinces
would surely be enough
to overpower caesar's rebellion with his
mind
made up pompey began to evacuate his
army
from southern italy
pompey marched his legions to the port
city of burundisium to make the crossing
degrees it didn't take long for caesar
to figure out where he was going
he abandoned all of his previous plans
and made a bee line for southern italy
by the time caesar arrived pompey had
occupied brundysium and half of his
army had already sailed away caesar
besieged the city
but a siege wouldn't do any good once
pompey's ships returned
he ordered a small fleet built and used
them to haul dirt
and rocks and wood out into the harbor
they used the material to begin building
a barrier or a breakwater to prevent the
pompans from escaping
pompey couldn't let this happen he
responded by sending
out ships of his own to slow down the
construction
there was skirmishing back and forth for
several days
and before caesar could complete his
breakwater the pompeian fleet returned
pompey and the rest of his supporters
set sail for greece
they would live to fight another day
[Music]
this was a missed opportunity for caesar
but nevertheless
the pompeian flight meant that italy was
now firmly under his control
it had been approximately two months
since
caesar crossed the rubicon he was now
finally free to enter rome
the reception was not what he expected
the place was a ghost town
those who could had fled the city those
who couldn't
opted to stay indoors after all caesar
was a traitor an enemy of the republic
and people had good reason to expect a
bloodbath
but caesar wasn't here for blood he
needed something else
[Music]
upon entering the city he immediately
called for a meeting of the senate
rome's best and brightest had gone with
pompey but there were a few senators
still in the city
caesar told this little makeshift senate
that he wanted
access to rome's treasury he was
desperate
he was already paying his legions with
ious
and he would need to continue paying
them for at least another year
now that pompey had escaped to greece
caesar gave some bs justification for
this request
saying that since rome no longer had to
worry about
fighting the gauls the money previously
spent on that should go to him
instead his reasoning didn't make any
sense
but it didn't need to none of the
senators objected
in fact none of the senators said
anything
caesar decided to interpret their
silence as approval
which was not how voting worked but
whatever
then one of the few remaining tribunes
of the plebs a guy named mattelus
summoned his courage and vetoed caesar's
request
caesar stormed out of the senate house
he ordered his legionaries to occupy the
forum
and led a group of soldiers up to the
temple of saturn which
housed the roman treasury when he got
there
the temple was locked and boarded up
metellus stood before the entrance
blocking caesar's path and continuing to
exercise his veto
caesar approached metellus and told him
that if he didn't get out of the way
he would order his men to murder him
right there before the gods and
everyone after a beat mattelus decided
to step aside
caesar proceeded to plunder the
republic's treasury
and immediately began to settle up on
his ious
up until this incident caesar had
consistently argued that he was on the
right side of the law
by coming into rome and threatening to
murder public officials
he demonstrated how untrue that was the
rule of law
was dead rome was in the hands of a
conquering warlord
[Music]
even though caesar controlled italy he
was still
beset with enemies on all sides which
meant that he had an important decision
to make
pompey was in greece with two or three
legions and was already rallying the
combined
strength of the east to his banner
pompey
also had seven legions active in spain
which were continuing to operate
independently caesar joked that to his
west there was an
army without a general and to his east
there was a general without an army
he could only deal with one of these
threats at a time but which would it be
east or west after some deliberation
caesar decided to head west to deal with
spain first
here was his reasoning at this moment
pompey was in no position to attack
if caesar spent a year campaigning in
spain italy would be
relatively safe the opposite was not
true if caesar spent a year campaigning
in greece
italy would probably fall to the spanish
legions
spain was the immediate threat greece
was the future threat
the immediate threat had to be dealt
with first
this must have been an agonizing
decision
caesar understood that pompey would
become more and more powerful
as the war dragged on in his absence
caesar would leave behind marc anthony
as the informal
governor of italy had things gone
differently this would have been
labienus's job
but he was with the pompeians now and
caesar needed a new number two that he
could rely on
for the moment anthony was that man
although as we'll discover
good help is hard to find and anthony
was no labienus
caesar prepared to split his army he
sent
three legions to capture sicily with
orders to continue on to africa if they
were successful
he sent another legion to capture
sardinia which was close enough to italy
that they could return
if something went wrong both of these
expeditions would require naval support
which meant that caesar would travel to
spain with his remaining three legions
on foot finally he sent orders to his
six
remaining legions in gaul instructing
them to break
camp and get themselves to spain as
quickly as possible
they would beat him there but that was
fine because time was of the essence
every day caesar spent in spain pompey
would be gathering strength
in greece
[Music]
you